[Musik]
hörst du mich nele und herzlich
willkommen zum emotionalsten
herzergreifenden und auch prominentesten
teppich der ein herz für kinder gala auf
dieses jahr ist es so wichtig den
kindern den hilflosesten den kleinsten
zu helfen und diese zu unterstützen
spendet was das zeug hält ist jetzt am
telefon und nehmen die spenden ging mit
ganz ganz vielen anderen prominenten und
einer tollen show kinder sollten jedem
oder hoffentlich leben wirklich am
herzen liegen und gerade die wenn die
not geraten dann können die ja wirklich
gar nichts dafür
ich weiß auch dass bei einigen leuten
bestimmt dieses jahr auch das geld ein
bisschen knapp ist und wenn es diesmal
nicht
bei dem 100 euro sind sondern diesmal
nur zehn und wenn es bei dem einheitlich
10.000 sind sondern vielleicht nur 1000
finde ich es an sich schon eine gute
sache trotzdem
[Musik]
ich bin so glücklich und dankbar dass
diese veranstaltung dieses jahr damit
trotz bewohner doch stattfindet weil wir
müssen und wir dürfen nicht vergessen
dass auch in dieser zeit viele kinder
leider es ganz schwer haben was ich am
meisten bewundert habe ist dass diese
dass diese kinder eigentlich ein alles
verziehen haben also die haben ja wenn
man die geschichten kommen wir jetzt
schon im kreis sitzt dann aber sie haben
sachen erlebt muss ich so sagen
gewalt in der familie sexuelle nötigung
sie waren in der psychiatrie sie sie
wurden tage lang in einer wohnung
vergessen und wenn man die wirklich
trifft und mit ihnen redet dann dann
freuen sie sich und fragen ein kommst du
jetzt jede woche der rocker wollte auch
noch verstärkt natürlich 100 euro und
ist dass es im eigenen portemonnaie hier
sogar
[Musik]
nun war es ein hartes jahr was würdest
du all denen da draußen sagen die sagen
ob es der warte es ist ende des jahres
wir müssen noch geschenke besorgen jetzt
auch noch was zu spenden bei mir ist es
wirklich knapp viele leute haben auch
finanzielle sorgen aber ich glaube wenn
dieses jahr etwas beigebracht hat dann
auch was man dankbar sein sollte für das
was man hat und wenn man sich in
erinnerung ruft dass andere menschen
nicht einmal das haben glaube ich
spendet man vielleicht sogar in dieses
jahr leichter als die anderen jahre weil
man selber mal in der situation war wo
man gemerkt hat so führt das also an
wenn nicht alles rund läuft
letzten endes war 2020 glaube eine sehr
sehr große challenge für uns alle sehr
sehr große herausforderung für die einen
mehr für die anderen weniger
aber ich glaube zusammenhalt war ist
dieses jahr wichtiger denn je
was ich besonders berührend finde ist
wenn sich zum beispiel auch ältere
rentner melden und sagen ich habe nicht
so viel rente aber ich möchte auch gerne
was geben und dann zählen auch fünf euro
[Musik]
bitte spenden wie viel sie spenden
jetzt
[Musik]
das schlimmste für mich ist wenn ich
traurige kinderaugen see und letztes
jahr wurden 18 millionen euro gesammelt
es muss mir mal überlegen es kommt auch
100 prozent der spender an
alle spenden also ich meine hand habe
schon gehört ist es ganz einfach ich
glaube man kann über paypal spät so
sieht so aus es gibt bewohner die
wünschen eingeblendet ist 08 02 und
dreimal die 10 genau
ich werde auch spenden unbedingt und ich
hoffe dass ganz viele spenden
zusammenkommen und und alle können in
der vorbereitungszeit was gutes tun
insofern tut es nele es war ein traum
vielen lang ein weihnachtsbaum der
herzen und ich würde gerne ein küsschen
links und rechts geben mit plexiglas wir
hoffen auf ganz viele spenden ihnen
einen wunderschönen abend vielen dank
dass sie dabei waren bleiben sie dran
ganz genau
[Musik]